(upbeat music)
- Hi, were at the Priscilla
Ono salon in Montebello,
and we're here to get some
Instagram-worthy nails.
- We see a lot of moms in
Hollywood wearing these nails,
which we think is amazing
because we don't know
how the hell you do that.
- I'm fascinated by them
to be honest with you,
which is why I am excited
about this challenge.
I don't know how they live,
maybe they have nannies.
(laughing)
Maybe the have housekeepers.
- Before I had children,
I would go get my nails
done every other week.
- I don't get my nails
done, I don't see the point.
I'm busy and I'm a mom and
they get dirty and they chip.
- How long does it take to do this?
An hour, no.
- I really hope I don't
get poop under my nails.
- I'm just really nervous about, like,
the amount of bacteria
that's going to collect.
Here goes nothing, operation
Awesome Hollywood Nails.
(upbeat music)
- Do you get a lot of moms in here?
- Yeah, quite a lot.
But actually they coming back like
after two weeks, after a month.
- So, like when I was growing up,
every mom I knew had acrylic nails.
It's like Lee Press-Ons times one million.
- I'm going to try to pick up the phone.
I'm just like, lightly tapping.
And I'm used to just
banging on this phone,
and maybe I don't need to tap so hard.
- I feel like I'm looking at the hands
of a different person.
(upbeat electronic music)
- I feel like I'm turning into a vampire.
- I gave up everything good
about having opposable thumbs.
I did it all for beauty.
- I'm about to try chopsticks
for the first time with these nails.
Let's see oh okay.
So I had a little difficulty there,
(laughing)
Already I can feel that
this nail's in the way.
It was challenging.
So I'm going to make my first dinner.
I'm a little hesitant because
I had planned on making chicken.
I'm really freaked out about
touching the raw chicken.
Cons of being a parent
with Instagram nails,
was actually just, like,
my constant fear of bing unsanitary.
(laughing)
So I came up with the solution
for my raw chicken dilemma.
(snapping)
Tongs!
- I'm a working mom,
and my job involves my hands.
I want to rip these nails
off, they are ruining my life.
Watch me type.
(laughing)
- I think Morgan struggled a lot.
- Like, and I'm a professional writer,
so it's not going that awesome.
- So I just changed
someone's poo-poo diaper.
Even though I protected my
nails, they still stink.
And I just kept feeling like,
oh my God, these aren't
sanitary and this is so gross.
They're so amazing.
- This isn't about motherhood but still,
my friend Chrissy who I think
is really awesome and cool,
told me that she thought
that my nails looked awesome.
And then that totally changed
my whole perspective on it.
She is really cool!
Like, who am I now?
Am I the fat-ass bitch?
- Okay, so I found a
positive for the nails.
Picking food out of your children's hair.
When you're a parent, you
do things for your children,
like pick their nose and
clean out their earwax
from time to time.
(singing a note)
- I think Ochi did a
million times better than me
with these hands.
(laughing)
But my daughter is like, really into them.
Which is the cutest.
So she was so into them, she
went and got with my mom,
- A fancy...
- Aww!
- Accent nail pedicure
fort the first time.
There are women who have,
like, mastered this.
I am not one of them.
That feeling you get like
if your pants are too tight
or like you bra's uncomfortable.
Just like "ah if I could
just take this bra off,
I could concentrate."
That's how I felt now.
(squeals)
- My nails are like, a brush
and a comb, all in one.
So the pros of being a
mom with these nails,
is that your kids pretty much always have
a toy or a shiny distraction around.
- I like this, mama.
- Okay, cool!
(beeping)
I put my credit card in the parking meter,
and then I couldn't get it out.
Fortunately this nice
guy walked by and like,
"Excuse me but could you
please take my credit card
out of the reader for me?"
- This week I lived with
10 blades of terror.
It was hard.
(laughing)
- They didn't really make
me feel more feminine.
They made me feel like
I was having more fun.
It was just another
accessory, like an earring,
or like a lip color.
- My opinion of the women who are able to
rock motherhood with these nails.
Power to you, sister, that is bad-ass.
- Who knew that having these
Instagram nails would be
so fun and would be such a
like, fun bonding
experience for the family.
(laughing)